this is sparta hmm training this is
Spartan training 300 has to be one of
the most over-the-top examples of pure
machismo ever put to film what's
impressive is that the true story of the
Spartans is possibly even more
incredible it's true for instance that a
single Spartan warrior was considered at
the time to be worth several men of any
other state and it's true that 300
Spartan warriors really did manage to
face off against thousands of Persians
and humiliate those armies with their
superior combat skills Spartan warriors
are the stuff of legend but in this case
the reality might actually be able to
live up to the myth that said there are
also some common misconceptions
surrounding Spartan training and it
likely isn't quite what you imagined so
the question is how did they train and
what can we learn from them
[Music]
[Applause]
unfortunately we actually know
relatively little about the specifics of
Spartan training there are a few things
we hold to be true though it is commonly
believed for instance that newborn
children considered too weak for combat
would be discarded at birth to either
die in the wilderness or demonstrate
their ability to survive and we know
that training began at the age of seven
when Spartan then would be entered into
a kind of boot camp called the Agoge
here they would then be required to live
and trained among their peers and a
culture of competition and teasing was
encouraged at the age of twelve spartan
boys would graduate and be considered
youths at which point the training
intensified now they'd be required to go
barefoot this would not only toughen
them up but would also help them to
develop greater athleticism and agility
as a result of their lack of Footwear we
knew today that there is a lot of truth
to this that freeing your feet allows
you to tap into greater proprioceptive
to anchor yourself to the ground and
even to increase flexibility by
massaging the fasciae at the same time
there are also given just a single thin
cloak called a fine ki kiss I have no
idea from saying that correctly to wear
come any type of weather again this was
intended to toughen them up
psychologically but it would also help
them to adapt to extreme temperatures
they could fight in the bitter cold or
sweltering heat and we've discussed the
benefits of cold exposure on this
channel too it's also said that they
made their own beds by pulling reeds out
of rivers by hand no doubt great grip
training Spartans would also only be
given small amounts of food each day the
aim was to keep them lean and hungry and
sufficiently motivated moreover if they
wanted more food they were encouraged to
steal it punishment was brutal if you
were caught but this taught cunning and
foraging skills the punishment was not
for stealing but for not doing it well
enough not to get caught the food they
did receive was also an appetizing and
included the likes of black broth which
was made from pig's blood though it did
also contain some actual pork for
protein we can safely assume then that
Spartan warriors would have been a
particularly ripped and lean Bunch at
the age of 20 they became full time
members of the Sioux City ER and Spartan
army but continued to live in barracks
they were not permitted to marry and
become full-time members of Sparta and
age 30 we also know that Spartan women
were encouraged to engage in physical
exercise in order to encourage the birth
of strong children there's actually some
scientific basis for this if we consider
the role of epigenetics like wise men
were encouraged to choose women that
would offer strong genetic stock a quote
from Plutarch's life of age helios reads
according to Theophrastus archidamus
was fined by the ephors for marrying a
short woman for she will bear us they
said not kings but king 'let's this
likely contributed to the notion that
spartans were particularly massive and
this illusion of greater size was also
encouraged by growing long hair all this
points to a picture of an elite warrior
culture of men whose training began even
prior to their conception and who had no
choice but to become incredibly mentally
tough and resilient the competitive and
mean-spirited atmosphere ensured
testosterone levels were high and the
harsh conditions made them physically
and mentally bulletproof it's been said
that the Spartans going into battle was
actually more comfortable than their
training so that's the ethos and the
spirit of Spartan training but what
about the actual practical application
what about the sets and reps and
exercise selection we have some reports
of the physical training that Spartans
underwent from sources such as Greek
biographer and writer Plutarch but these
are generally regarded as being somewhat
unreliable Plutarch for instance was
born during the mid 1st century AD a
little late in the day sparta ceased to
be as we know it by around the mid 4th
century BC we know that from 12 onwards
though youth have learned survival
skills such as foraging and camping we
might also presume that a Spartan
training program would incorporate
weapons training and calisthenics
although there's no concrete evidence to
suggest this according to the historians
over at the ask historian subreddit
ancient Greeks made a sharp distinction
between athletic training and the
training of a warrior the theory here
goes as we know today that an athlete
requires a moderate amount of stress
exposure to trigger an adaptation but
that they are then required to rest and
recover and that this is just as
important the ancient Greeks knew of the
importance of protein for building
muscle and of rest
thus the diet and regimen of an athlete
should be highly strict and consistent a
warrior on the other hand needs to be
able to survive on little food and
endure extreme sleep deprivation from
Plutarch's the life of Phillip pointman
they told him and it was the truth that
the habit of body and mode of life per
athlete and soldier were totally
different and particularly that their
diet and training were not the same
since the one required much sleep
continuous a surfeit of food and fixed
periods of activity and repose in order
to preserve or improve the condition
which the slightest influence or the
least departure from routine is apt to
change for the worse whereas the soldier
ought to be conversing with all sorts of
irregularity and all sorts of inequality
and above all should accustom himself to
ensure lack of food easily and lack of
sleep on hearing this fill appointment
not only shunned athletics himself and
derided them but also in later times as
a commander banished from the army all
forms of them with every possible mark
of reproach and dishonor on the ground
that they rendered useless for the
inevitable struggle of battle men who
would otherwise be most serviceable so
contrary to popular belief Spartans
weren't actually covered in rippling
muscle and they spent less time than
average civilians of other cultures in
the gymnasiums successes following their
battle at Thermopylae then were largely
down to the Army's reputation along with
practical decisions such as the fact
this was the only Greek army known to be
subdivided into platoon sized units with
their own officers and to march in step
two fleets they understood maneuvers
such as wheeling and counter marching
and commands could be passed down
through the ranks and they were decked
in matching red and bronze uniforms that
made them appear as a singular mass on
the battlefield these seemingly basic
features set the armies apart more so
than their physical prowess a modern
Spartan training program focusing on
resistance training HIIT workouts and
weapons training then would actually be
inaccurate the training that Greek
warriors actually underwent appears to
have been more focused on gymnastics
ability and agility here is a quote from
Nepos describing Eponine owned us the
Theban commander credits to read it to
user if it crates for digging all this
stuff up after he grew up and began to
apply himself to gymnastic exercise he's
not so much to increase the strength as
the agility of his body for he thought
that strength suited the purpose of
wrestlers but that agility conduced
to excellence in war he used to exercise
himself very much therefore in running
and wrestling as long as he could
grapple and contend standing with his
adversary a quote from Aristotle's
politics explains meanwhile that
Spartans incorporated laborious exercise
in the belief that it would make their
boys animal in nature and contribute to
manly courage some sports might have
been incorporated into warrior training
but specifically those that built the
agility and an all-rounders body
wrestling is a likely candidate
according to some sources they're not
others as is climbing and surprisingly
dance although perhaps this shouldn't be
a surprise as many other warriors and
athletes including Bruce Lee have made
the connection between dance and
improved proprioceptive it's also more
than likely that Spartan training would
have utilized drills and challenges that
directly related to the skills they used
in combat such as marching long
distances to build immense stamina say
we know very little of Spartan training
but we do know enough to draw some basic
conclusions Spartans did not train to
build large muscle raw strength was
actually considered relatively
unimportant one report Xenophon's
adjusts aleus suggested that the
hoplites the civilian units actually had
superior physiques instead what really
set them apart was their military
training and more so their psychological
and physical resilience they were agile
fierce and unyielding training in the
cold barefoot
ripping weeds out of the ground with
your hands that will turn you into a
truly formidable opponent throw in some
gymnastics training undying loyalty to
your troops and a never-say-die attitude
and it's no wonder that the Spartans
were feared for so many years there are
definitely things we can learn from this
type of training our modern lifestyles
have made us incredibly soft by
comparison if you want to train more
like a Spartan then trained outdoors
take your top off and get cold and wet
training barefoot and pull up things
with bare hands
if you want to see a Spartan training
inspired workout program that you can
use then head over to the bio near comm
where I've just uploaded something you
can try out I'll leave the link in the
description down below keep in mind
though that there are also some deficits
in Spartan training and to view them as
these perfect warriors would be a bit
disingenuous it's been suggested that
the Thebans victory is able to Spartans
in the fourth century BC might have been
a result of the greater time that the
former spent in the gymnasiums wrestling
and exercising these guys might have
benefited from a bit of extra resistance
training so as Bruce Lee would say we
should absorb what is useful and
disregard the rest so I hope you found
this video useful interesting guys if it
did then please leave a like please
share it around that helps me out
immensely let me know in the comments
down below if there's anything I missed
and also let me know if there are any
other examples of historical training
that you'd like me to take a look at any
other historical warriors I've got lots
more coming up in future videos I'll be
looking at the wim HOF method I've got
one coming up on how to assess a Health
Study if that all sounds good then
thanks a ton for watching and I'll see
you next time bye for now